PrepClass is an academic
solutions provider.
We help students [? direct ?]
in local tests and examinations
to prepare by providing
them with past questions,
along with detailed answers and
solutions to those questions.
We also help parents
who are looking
to get tutors for their children
who are specific needs, to find
tutors that are best fit for
their kids, and engage them.
Regarding technology challenges.
I would generally say
they kind of reduced
as we went on, because we
learned to be more handy
and use simpler things.
When we started,
it was a lot more
elaborate in terms of
product development, like I
said before.
So we wanted it to be
perfect and all of that,
but as we went on we learned
to put more effort on things
that the market emphasizes.
And then, managing
my own psyche means
keeping a positive
outlook irrespective
of whatever is
happening, because it
affects your productivity a lot.
Sometimes you have
to wonder why sales
was lower than you expected, or
why the next big thing didn't
turn out so big.
Or you come up with this
idea and the whole team
is going crazy,
like, Oh, this is
the silver bullet, and stuff.
And two weeks later you're like,
Oh no, that didn't work at all.
It's easy to get
negative about it,
but then that affects your
productivity a whole lot,
especially because you're
still running a small team.
And the outlook of the founders
gets to affect everyone else.
At the beginning, there
was no "register for free,"
for instance.
You had to pay before you had
any access to our platform.
In time, we realized we have
to get people into the door.
At least let them
have an account.
Let them see what the platform
looks like on the back end,
and then let them also get
access to some questions
before they decide, OK, I want
to put my money into this.
So those were some of the
evolutionary processes that
happened in terms of
subscription model.
So first it was, you
visited the platform
but you had to pay for
you to come in at all.
Then at some point, we decided
to have a free version where
you get to access a
limited number of questions
and you get to have
a free account.
And then you have
to pay a premium fee
if you want access to rest.
And later on we did a
bit of a [INAUDIBLE]
that now brings some
revenue, as well,
but it's not a
subscription-based model.
It's more an outlook.
You decide, OK, I
want to do this.
And it's not what
everybody does,
but it can create
value if it works.
It's a risk, right?
But if it works it
can create value.
And I think that's where
entrepreneurship begins.
I don't think it begins
when you quite your job
or start out your own business
or do anything so dramatic,
as the case may.
But if you have the
initiative, even
if you're working at a job,
to do things differently,
and it's going to create
value not only for yourself
but for the entire company, or
the community that you're in,
or the entire society.
I think that's being
entrepreneurial.